[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
six bets you guys love that's what we're
talking about today
hey my MB so excited to see you MB is in
the building hey what we talking about
today fellas
man it's good to be on the show shout
out the whole app Community I'm repping
for all my boys in the app
let's get this going man I I think we're
gonna have some fun today
yes sir yeah we we got we got some
things to talk about Greg but I feel
like we you have to address a little bit
what's going on with your Golden State
Warriors I'm hearing I have sources
telling me that the Dynasty's over
Dynasty's over why is these over seasons
over maybe trade Steph Curry get some
picks Dynasty's over whoa whoa whoa whoa
you
Ryan you have to relax you have to relax
talking about the dynasties over Dynasty
is not over Steph Curry is not going
anywhere hey in the words in the words
of Aaron Rodgers a couple of years ago
r e l a x relax they might make a move
or two we're just filling out the young
guys we're just filling out the young
guys I'll tell you what's going on this
I I'm gonna take up a whole five minutes
talking about the words Max we might
want to keep this thing going because
like I'll tell you what's going on
what's going on is it's a lot of young
guys that that are not on the same page
they're trying to find their roles
they're trying to figure out am I a
score am I a Defender should I slash and
dash should I spot up at the three like
they're young they're trying to figure
out what they're doing we're going to
give them some time and if they don't
figure it out we're not going to waste
this Championship window because Ryan it
sounds like a lot of excuse making Greg
all right I was just about to ask hold
on what does this sound like you do
remember what happened last season right
hey oh whoa yeah that was that that's
your Boston Celtics your favorite team
this is a little too soon Greg it was
only a few months ago I'm just saying
I'm the fact facts are facts but let's
get to the show let's let's let's let's
start this welcome to the show
everybody that's in the Stream watching
us my name is Greg Ivory to the next to
me right next to me is Michael Bolin and
next to him is producer Ryan usually we
give out six or six Best Bets but today
we got the man of the app here my man MB
you guys see him in the app all the time
he's here so we're switching things up
and we're talking bets but it's about
you yes you it's bets that you love
drop your Best Bets in the chat uh for
the Lakers Suns game and we'll look at
them and we'll cook up a same game
parlay all together all right let's pick
our first leg fellas
Ryan
yeah talk to us so I'm looking through
the chat right now uh I I'm just gonna
get in front of this right now I see way
too many Lakers money line we want to
win this parlay oh my God We're not
gonna do that yeah
uh Lakers Lakers by Squad said Lakers
money line uh A.D anytime three and
Westbrook eight plus this is I don't
think there's no it's not like any time
touchdown anytime three
somebody really said that oh my gosh
anytime three see this we need good
energy Good Vibes in the comments
because we're actually trying to hit a
parlay that's gonna win so I'm on my
phone I'm looking up FanDuel right now
I'm gonna get in here and uh see if I
can find something you you Ryan you know
me I'm going big I'm going big yeah if I
go too big if I go too big y'all know
how to tame me and be like gee that's
not it we're not looking for that we
need winners so you know what I'm saying
MB what's what's your strategy when
you're looking for these parlays
basically I'm looking at matchups and I
think tonight is a really bad matchup
for the Lakers they've started off this
season pretty underwhelming LeBron's out
Russell Westbrook who will get to a
little bit later is playing better in a
bench role they're kind of up and down I
don't know I don't really I've never
liked the Lakers I'm a bulls fan I
always look forward to the Bulls beating
the Lakers on Christmas day so Lakers
money line is out for me but the Chicago
Kid
Jalen Jolly or Jaylene Jolly has A.D
over on rebounds that's interesting the
Suns take a lot of jumpers could maybe
put that in there I'm curious to see
what you guys think though
I also wanted to throw in two options
here we have Jay scardo saying A.D under
25 points and then J High uh DeAndre
eight in over nine and a half rebounds I
like that eight and eight I like that
I I think I like that
Aiden is an interesting one yeah Aiden's
an interesting one he he's pretty much a
vacuum down there I don't think that the
Lakers have a very good chance of
winning that probably means we're going
to see a lot of bad shots there's a lot
of bad shot makers on that team yeah I
don't know what the hell Kendrick nuns
doing these days he's not very good so
he he averages 10 10 rebounds all we
need is what eight rhyme
no we need time
oh we need 10. yeah yeah so I like
I like the 10. I think 80 is gonna have
a field day down there so if we want to
put one in there Ryan what do you think
you're the voice of reason you're in the
chat okay we here's what we can do we
can bet if we feel a little bit more
comfortable we can bet the eight plus I
will say it is scaring me a tad bit that
over nine and a half rebounds is plus
one of six because that should be a lot
easier than
that's a good I mean that's following
the money that's following the line I'm
actually interested in betting it down a
little bit okay
might not be the worst play just to kind
of cover ourselves see what that number
looks like okay
it's a leg it's a leg Ryan it's a leg
we're not straight bending here we're
trying to build this parlay shout out to
whoever gave us that tip though shout
out to whoever gave us that tip we
appreciate you let's move on let's move
on to the next leg Ryan do you have
anybody in the chat let me hop in the
chat Ryan but just go ahead take it away
yeah I wanted to shout out Jay High I
believe he was the one who dropped that
um we've got uh the onions my guy back
in here uh to have a Booker for 40
tonight
under 40.
that'll be like minus 5 000. uh we've
got Veach one two three uh that says
Mikhail 15 plus points
okay so for me
I took a look at these these games a
little bit earlier doing my research I
think Mikhail Bridges that's like a
close number my bet would have been
Bridges two plus threes I I thought I
wrote it down let me let me take a peek
uh plus 145 so it's plus money but this
isn't about me I don't hate the bridges
play I think 15 points may be a little
too much for this parlay okay oh you
think it's a little bit too much Envy
yeah I mean you're you're depending on a
guy who's like this third option at best
to really have a big game and you got to
protect against the potential blowout
I can see him maybe not playing in the
fourth quarter but I'm curious what do
you think right he averages 15. they're
playing the Lakers at home my man just
did he just he just showboated against
Klay Thompson he's filling himself so
that's where this is coming from
he's top of mind for you yeah that's a
good point that's a good problem but but
there's no shade all I'm saying is my
man is in his bag if we go look at his
points 13 13 23 15. I mean he he's he's
in his Michael Bridges bag I'm not
saying he's in Steph Curry back but like
my man's like in his bag but 15 points I
just said 13 13 and
I don't know that that just honestly
talked me out of it yeah you guys are
watching how I do this in real time I
went to go see what 10 plus looked like
and it's minus 600 and I don't think
that's that's juicy enough for us we do
have another take in here if you guys
want to discuss something else we have
uh let's yeah we got Michael Trice
saying Lonnie Walker three threes three
plus threes Lonnie Walker San Antonio
Spurs Legend now on the Los Angeles
Lakers
what do we think I'm a big Lonnie Walker
guy I won't lie Lonnie Walker three plus
threes
let's see
oh geez I mean is it I mean his number's
at one and a half
but okay plus 175.
they're gonna have to bowling you said
they're gonna be behind they're gonna
have to check up shots
I that's the thing I think I mean if
we're gonna get risky I'd rather get
risky on the Laker side because they are
going to shoot some more volume Lonnie
Walker's a pretty good player I'm not
necessarily sure I love the three point
or three threes play but at plus 175
if the if the man in the chat really
likes it I consider it I I like Lonnie
Walker but better before he cut his head
hold on before we lock in I say we lock
in and Lonnie Becker uh Alani Walker bet
I'm sorry let's lock in a Lonnie Walker
bet but are you looking to chat I'm
looking in the chat and I see nugs fan01
Lonnie Walker 15 plus points I also see
midg 3221 says Lonnie Walker 15 plus
points
Ryan like they're in here they're
they're they're they're asking for
Lonnie Walker over 15 and a half is it
15 or 14 and a half it's never seen that
but if they want 15 plus the people want
15 plus I'll give them 15 plus
there we go minus 150. I like that
number let's take it that's a leg that's
another leg look at that we're already
plus money plus money
this is good
you got your you don't got the handy
dandy iPad but the trusty iPhone's
coming through right now hey I got the
trusty Dusty phone hey what about hey
hold on what about this for Pat bath
under in this point total I got it from
uh
happy happy 56.85
shout out shout out hoppy man he's a
legend we have posted a few of his
parlays in the community so shout out
hoppy hey he's a he's sharp he's a shark
if we have to play the unders we gotta
play the end hey we gotta play this for
The Vibes hey Michael Bolin just like
vouched for hoppy he's a sharp he's in
the shot Community he's always you know
giving giving us content giving us ideas
giving us uh bets you know what I'm
saying so
dude it's five points I mean like under
five and a half I just think it's
hilarious we're doing this I I'm down to
fade him though I got no bad loving me
let's do it
It's Pat Biv bro I know I know I know he
plays defense
okay okay all right cool we've got three
legs boys all right two two more two
more dude I don't know if you see Jay
underscore jr24 Devin Booker two plus
threes I I literally just saw that I
literally let's knock that that's a lock
that's a lot let's lock that in yeah
because I literally just saw that all
right somebody said all right peep this
you're locking it in Ryan
peep this one somebody Philip Marquez
said how about Booker five rebounds the
last five games he's had eight two eight
and five
that was only four games that was only
four games that he listed but I
appreciate I appreciate the effort
though because Ryan knows when we go to
the chat they're minimal in like their
effort and you know the yeah the odds
that they give us and you know like the
handicapping that's good that's good
handicapping right now
those are Scoops those are scoops
those are Scoops uh I I you guys ain't
talking about it so I'ma just move on uh
Michael Bridges we're back to Michael
Bridges uh over five and a half rebounds
West doe West doe is in the comments
saying Michael bridges over five and a
half you guys did not say anything so I
am going to move on
Michael Trice Michael Trice Austin
Reeves two threes is plus 140. we know
AR-15 is going to put him up he's
definitely like that he's definitely
like that I kind of like this pick who
dropped that right again because I think
that
Ryan we know AR-15 is going to put up
the shots Michael Trice Michael Trice
AR15 two threes is plus
140. okay I will I will also say we have
a lot of resistance to the pat to fading
Pat Bev at under five and a half I feel
like seeing that
yeah we're gonna are we about to walk
back a leg
we might gotta take it away we might
have to take it back this is about the
people yeah anyway hey wait hey hold on
before we do that I have to look at his
recent stats Pat Bev Pat Patrick Beverly
I'm trying I'm having trouble
spelling all right hold on oh wait wait
wait guys wait three points Four Points
two points Five Points in his last four
games
saying
he fits and yell
and yell team like okay so I'm seeing
I'm seeing I'm seeing the the chat some
people are saying it's it's low for a
parlay that could be the reason I mean
if he hits two threes we're smoke but
hoppy jumped in the chat said make the
chat happy take pat Bev off but keep
track of it maybe play it as a single I
don't know I won't make the final
decision but I love how the chat's
interacting with each other
seems like the chat consensus says we
may need to get another picture okay
the chat is saying take it out so let's
take it we're men of the people but I I
will I'm going to request the chat
figure it out and then give us okay
don't don't let us talk about it and
then be like no no no no no no
trying to do 20 different things over
here exactly wait 6'4 says this is a big
game for him so he might go over okay
okay Jay High Jay highs in the comments
guys he's in the chat saying campaign
six assists
oh now starting with Chris Fallout so
let's do that
plus 330. all right we need a little bit
of juice we need a little bit of juice
here I think if we're gonna do five legs
you know I mean I mean I think we've
covered
two stars on the sun side who got who's
got who's got anything for the Lakers if
you got a Lakers game for A.D
what you what you got Greg Darien A5 a a
bowling we're connecting Dots here it's
it's it's The Vibes because darion85
says no A.D on the ticket and you just
mentioned A.D so
somebody got to have a lock though come
in with a handicap let us know he also
shouted shout out to Darien yeah he
shouted you out for the question yes sir
I appreciate my bro from Chicago I feel
you bro uh listen I I agree I'm not the
biggest ad fan he's made of glass and we
all know what that is but it it would be
kind of weird to not have him on this
ticket so if you got a hey D play please
drop it let's go hey Austin all right
here we go six four we're just waiting
for A.D player or or we could go with
six four because he's I'm back on AR-15
Austin reads 10 points we know he's
gonna put up some shots guys we know
he's gonna shoot some threes that's the
thing we know he's going to we just got
to know if he's gonna we just don't know
if he's gonna make that's that's the
other thing
he's gonna shoot quiet
no no hold on it's only because it's
minus 160. I don't know what it does to
this
10 points that juicified it Ryan how
juicy are you trying to get
if I'm doing ah yeah I mean this is good
look this is this is good I I have just
like this inner desire I really want
this to hit so bad
me too me too and I feel like this I I
feel like this would hit
me
too
so make this community this is
community-led we we asked for the picks
they gave us the picks I I think this I
think this would hit I I would hate to
go like hunting for a plus money play
when we have five legs for Plus 631.
that's what I'm saying hey we need a
Vibe check comments chat you guys give
us a Vibe check give us thumbs up we
need thumbs up you guys are rocking
thumbs down
if you guys are rocking we need a Vibe
check we got to fill the Vibes out but
Ryan you were you were definitely like I
feel you bro but plus 631 and it's
trying to go down you see it's going
down it's trying it's trying it's trying
it's trying to go down plus 631
I mean
I like it
I yeah
I'm with it this is good I mean plus 6
30 five legs all all of them I see
potentially being pretty easy all right
guys I'm in the chat I'm in the chat I
got six four saying I love it JR
jr24 says let's go let's run it Kelly
Bean four thumbs up emojis spicy spun
says it's a lock Midge three two hey
they're all coming in giving me thumbs
up thumbs up J High thumbs up of course
we're gonna get some haters Jets Yanks
Nets oh thumbs down but that's okay
based on the username he's just sad to
begin with
one more uh one more I got Hooper status
22 he's giving us a thumbs up I think we
should lock this in guys let's lock it
in love the chat love love the
engagement man everybody everybody
contributing
this is this feels like a lot to me I
don't know what do you think Ryan I I
agree so if you were to put 100 down
you're walking away with 631 and just as
a refresher DeAndre ayton eight plus
rebounds Lonnie Walker 15 plus points
Devin Booker two plus made threes
campaign six plus assists and Austin
Reeves AR-15 to score 10 plus points
make sure you guys tell us on FanDuel go
on over put this bed in you guys helped
us this is your this is your parlay
yours and our parlay together make sure
you guys go over and on over to FanDuel
and tail with us but before we move on
from the Lakers
Russell Westbrook is now the favorite
for six men of the Year sitting at plus
150 a month ago he couldn't catch a
break but now we're talking about him
being the favorite for the Sixth Man
is it like this is this is mind-boggling
they were calling them a meme they were
making a means about him Ryan
they were they were they were talking
about them they were slandering this
man's name like he is not a first ballot
Hall of Famer
what do you guys think what does the
chat think about Russell I was going to
say wrestler no I was going to say
Wilson but no Russell Westbrook Russell
Westbrook Brody what do you guys think
about him uh being the favorite for six
men of the year
it's really interesting right like the
Fall From Grace I think was pretty
public people were calling them trash
calling them West brick he's actually
one of my favorite players ever honestly
like the way he kind of changed the
point guard positioned him and guys like
Derrick Rose I'm from Chicago so D Rose
very high up there for me too
but now in this new role later in his
career you can see the Lakers need
scoring they need help in that second
wave he's doing a great job I think of
controlling that second that that bench
offense Distributing scoring points and
the Lakers record isn't great but he's
like the shining bright moment I guess
for the Lakers this year so plus 150 I
think he started out at plus 2400 in
October so if you got in way early
that's like incredible value because if
he keeps this up he's definitely a lot
yeah that would be my only concern is
like sustainability right it's like at
this point in his career can he do this
for a whole 82 Game season I don't know
I agree with bowling I mean like
what did I say right can he do this for
82 Game season do you know who we're
talking about we're talking about what's
Russell Westbrook like if he wasn't on
the Lakers my man will be average in a
triple double without a doubt without a
doubt without a doubt what are we
talking about
what are you talking about Ryan
I I let's see what the chat has to say I
can't I'm not what are you talking I'm
not doing this man you're talking about
girl we're talking about Russell
Westbrook first ballot Hall of Famer
yeah when he was in his prime I'm not
disappointed
my man can literally go to any other
team that's probably not playoff
contention but he will still drop a
triple double average a triple double
action
I listen dude I'm not disagreeing with
you about his resume I'm just saying
like at this point in his career I don't
think he's doing it for 82 games I let
me see what happens
yeah TomTom is saying incredible
username I incredible uh bro nobody's
saving the Lakers Jets Yanks Nets the
king of bad vibes right now saying
that's a bad bet uh boom baby 45 saying
Benedict matheran I disagree
uh junior saying when you put ego aside
in just your environment
uh when you don't reach your own
expectation when you don't reach your
own expectations best things can come
from it
that's the best take I think and I think
that was the that was the controversy
with Westbrook this year right like is
he going to accept a bench roll he's in
the back half of his career I tend to
lean closer to what Greg's talking about
I do think he's still got a lot of
talent and a lot to offer
he's getting too much money that's not
his fault but
when you see how he's playing if we're
talking specifically Sixth Man of the
Year I don't know who's gonna get I
don't know who can uh top him at this
point because they need him to do what
he's doing and I don't see it stopping
anytime soon
Michael Boland doesn't see it stopping
Ryan I don't know what's going on in his
head because we're talking about Russell
Westbrook the future all our favor and
uh I don't disagree
okay okay we can agree all right we you
don't disagree let's move on though
because Ben Simmons is returning to
Philly tonight for the first time and
we're all trying to figure out how to
bet let's pull up the game on FanDuel
and look at some of his crops I need
everybody in the chat to let us know
what Ben Simmons props you like and
don't like we want to hear from you
we'll pick a squad ride to bet
on top of our parlay that you guys
helped us pick so Ryan let's go to the
chat let's let's go to the chat and uh
first off Michael Boland before we go to
the chat
talk to me Ben Simmons is going back to
his old stomping grounds
how would you bet this well what angle
would you take when betting Ben Simmons
so Ben Simmons to me is a pretty
interesting cat right like he won Rookie
of the Year I believe I can't remember
the year but he he was a top 10 to 15
player for the beginning of his career
and then he gets The Yips and if you're
not familiar what The Yips are it's a
baseball term you can't throw the ball
to second base or back to the pitcher
he's just scared out of his mind and
can't get right after that game seven in
Philly I know Ryan producer Ryan hates
Philly so he was probably really happy
about that result
but I was time has passed and he's going
back he's playing better recently so I
think this is a good spot to maybe look
at some of his overs over ten and a half
points right now for him on FanDuel I
think that that's something that people
should consider
not gonna have to face and bead I know
that the environment's going to be crazy
and they're going to boo the hell out of
him and probably a lot of it is much
deserved for the way he went out
but he's got some pride I think in him
that even if he doesn't play well the
rest of the season I think he could
score 11 points in this basketball game
I'll just say this I'll just say this
Ben Simmons doesn't give me The Vibes
that like when the pressure is on he
turns up or like when the pressure's on
the dog comes out of like the dog comes
out that's true
I get timid Vibes when the pressure's on
so I'll just say that as I lead to
saying Ryan what does the chat like
because it's about the people what are
they talking about well the chat's
dropping some nice sex men of the Year
bets that I might take with bones
Highland and Christian Wood but we're
we're moving past it
those are good takes I like it
um let's see we've got six four says Ben
Simmons is going for 10 points eight
rebounds six assists
um
a spicy sponge Ben Simmons under one
point uh so they don't
there listen I this is the one thing I
will say about Philly that I do respect
in a way not fully uh respect was a
strong word I'm sorry I'll walk it back
but they bring the heat you walk into
that building they will let you know how
they feel for the entirety of the game
all 48 minutes so like you said Greg
it's like when the pressure is on is
that somebody that's going to step up to
the moment like Kyrie Irving when he
went back to Boston
they let them know how they felt for the
entire game and he didn't necessarily
rise to the occasion outside of game one
I I don't I don't know and it seems like
the chat is kind of starting to feel the
same way Junior orms saying I'm sorry
but Ben Simmons folds under the pressure
so this might be a Ben Simmons under
kind of night for us I know we like to
bring Good Vibes but sometimes bad vibes
wins you money okay so I love that
first of all that take is very strong
I'm not a person that bets unders often
and like that's how you make some money
you gotta look at it with a clear eye
instead of using your heart but in
regards to Ben Simmons I don't know
maybe it's the eternal optimist in me
but like you gotta be beat up enough
times to like make a statement right
like I know that Greg's take is probably
the right take he doesn't have that dog
in him we all know that we've known that
for years but in this moment your first
opportunity to just like make you don't
even gotta make a big statement bruh you
just gotta make six baskets four baskets
and and four free throws like it's
really not that much and B I feel you
and a lot of other people feel you but
the main thing is does Ben Simmons feel
you and he hasn't showed me previously
otherwise so this until then I'm going
to rock or what I've seen and I'm gonna
rock off of you know what he showed me
in those big games and so question for
you Greg could he have a good game
without having 12 to 15 points because I
think so I think you can fill the stat
sheet with absolutely six or seven
assists seven or eight boards listen
really exactly Philly's team is depleted
no hardened maybe no Harris no embiid
this feels like a good spot for the Nets
to really kind of beat them up so maybe
it's the other things that we know he
does well but the thing that scares me
like you keep saying is he doesn't have
that dog in him so maybe I'm just gonna
go in blindly and put some money on him
and hope for a good story but you guys
are probably on the right side I just
think you can't get beat up enough
to like really just take this tonight so
it's 11 points I think I'm gonna my man
my man mb's being optimistic I love it
and and I love I love I love the last
line my man Ryan said uh you you know
we're all about Good Vibes
but bad vibes is money you got to say it
one more time before we get out of here
Brian we love to give Good Vibes but
sometimes bad vibes makes you money
we do need to make a pick though we
didn't give a pick well all we said was
we you know we may bowling said he may
like the over but do so are we rocking
with the points I thought the under was
was locked like I thought we were
entertained and then bowling was
yeah all right so then everyone in the
chat seems to be on the under bowling
I I appreciate the optimism
it's fine honestly like that's the right
plan your line is perfect we like the
Good Vibes sometimes the bad vibes make
you money I'm not too proud to be the
person to say if it's under it's under
and I'll meet y'all at the cashier okay
so that is this is our Squad ride Ben
Simmons under 10 and a half points in
his return to Philadelphia with the
Brooklyn Nets tonight
Greg hey Ryan I'm gonna put that quote
on my wall in my uh
in one of my rooms uh I absolutely love
that but hey it's been it's been fun I
really had so much fun on this channel
can I can I drop a shout out real quick
go ahead do your thing
shout out to the entire AB Community
everyone knows the parlay
thank you for rocking with with us in
this chat if you post a screenshot in
community of you tailing this parlay and
it hits I'm giving out merch man this
has been really fun all right I'll let
you do your thing my bad no no this has
been fun this has been fun and if you
guys on the app don't know the man next
to me Michael Boland he is the man of
the app so if you guys are talking you
guys are probably talking to him if
you're talking to BR betting that's
probably him everything that's on the
app is Michael bowling so you want to
get tapped in you tap in with that guy
type in with Michael Bolin on the app
and he will hook you up he just said
he's giving away free t-shirts so tap in
with the guy producer Ryan
yeah I'll just leave it at that my name
is Greg Ivory uh hey we'll be back next
week
hey I'm out man I got to go watch some
bets I'm out of here peace
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]